These VO3 Tree AI ads are going
absolutely viral lately. They're all
created using a new prompting format
which is called JSON prompting. And
honestly, you can make some pretty sick
stuff with it. So, in this video, I will
show you exactly how you can do that.
Now, it all started when this person
right here started posting these IKEA
unboxing videos. You're not just limited
to using this IKEA format. You can do
different brands, different styles. You
can even do something with characters.
So, in this video, I will show you how
you can make this yourself. I will give
you all the prompts that you need to use
in order to get started with this, and I
will show you a few creative examples.
Before we dive in, let me tell you this.
There's quite a bit of buzz around the
word Jason prompting. Some people
believe it's a new magical spell that
automatically makes your videos look
insane. It's not the case at all. It's
just a way to structure your video. So,
you don't even need to use the JSON
prompting if you don't want to. In my
opinion, it works great for these type
of videos. Either way, I will share the
exact JSON prompt that I use to create a
really cool Starbucks ad like this one
or this perfumemer.
I also made this chip bolt that creates
the JSON prompts for you by just using
my link in description down below. Okay,
first let me get started with the
unboxing videos. So, what you want to do
is you want to go over to the platform
where you can get access to Google V3.
For me, I'm using Open Art. I will leave
a link to that in the description down
below, but you can also do this directly
on Google Flow. Now, what you want to do
next is you want to use the text to
video, not the image to video, but the
text to video model. Then you want to
switch it to V3. The reason why I'm
using Open Art is because I get access
to like all of these different AI video
generators. And in my opinion, that's
much easier than having multiple
different subscriptions. So, use model
VO3 Tree. Then, for the audio, you want
to leave that on because then you get
that cool sound effect with your video.
Resolution, you want to switch it over
to 1080p. And then for the video mode,
you can either choose fast or normal,
but fast is a lot cheaper, so I'm using
fast in this case as I want to save some
credits. Next up, you want to add in
your prompt. Now, I will share this
document with you with all the prompts I
use in this video. So, for me, I have
this labuba room transformation. That's
the first prompt that I'm going to use.
So, I'm actually going to copy all of
this. I'm going to go back to OpenArt.
And here, I'm going to enter in my
prompt. Now, this will cost me a few
credits to create. And while this video
is generating, let me just explain what
JSON prompting is. So basically, it's a
JavaScript form of code. It's actually a
lot more informative in this way.
Doesn't mean that you have to write it
like that, but if you can see with like
what's going on here, it's basically
giving us in the exact order of what's
going on, what we want to happen, what
type of camera, what type of lighting,
what type of room, what type of
elements. Basically, with that, it gives
the AI somewhat of a format. Most people
just say like, "Hey, box unboxing
explosion." That doesn't work. So, with
this style, you get something cool.
It's not quite labubu. It had a pretty
hard time with that. I reckon it is
because it's quite new. That was already
pretty cool. But let me now show you how
you can actually prompt like this. So,
you can make your own custom prompts.
And for that I have inside this document
I have my custom prompt. So if you click
on this link then you will be redirected
to chat and you will get access to my
custom bot. Now here you can simply ask
it to give me a JSON FO3 prompt of a box
opening room transformation in let's do
Tom and Jerry style. So now we hit enter
and what it does is I have trained it on
the exact format. So now it will write
this prompt for you. So, it made up all
of these details in this prompt itself.
If you want to change anything, you have
to do that yourself. I'm just going to
copy this and I'm going to go back to
open art. And here I'm actually going to
copy and paste in my prompt. And now we
just do the same thing. And then we have
a new video generated like this.
So, there you have it. That's quite
good. Honestly, you might want to try it
out a few more times because in my
experience, sometimes it doesn't work as
good as I hope to. But that just takes a
few generations. Now, let's do another
example. Next up, I had the idea of
doing a Pikachu in a Pokeball, and it
turned out quite awesome.
So, yeah. Isn't that quite insane?
Honestly, I love how the little
Pikachu's like pop out. And how you have
like a whole Pikachu themed bedroom for
anyone. Like if I was a kid, I would
love to have a bedroom like that. And
here I have one for Louis Vuitton, a
luxury brand. So that's possible as
well.
So the whole unboxing thing is fun, but
it's also a bit of a trend. You could
also use these kind of like formats to
create professional advertisements. Take
a look at this one of Apple for example.
[Music]
For this, you can literally use a prompt
like just this. Generate a cinematic
prompt for Samsung product launch or do
that for Apple, do that for any brand
you have in mind and it will spit out an
entire prompt for you that you can just
copy in here.
Now, with this Apple one, it took me a
few tries, but I honestly really love
this result. And actually, I want to
show you this one as well.
Just look at how insane this is if you
have a product. Now, let me show another
one of a Ferrari one that I did.
I've seen people do this with Tesla, all
kind of different cool things. And I'm
just very curious what you would do if
you have access to this and what you
would make out of this. Let me know in
the comments, please. Here you have
another one that I already showed in the
intro, but this one is of Starbucks.
[Applause]
This is sick. like this could literally
replace a $100,000 commercial that
people pay for. Then this one is my
absolute favorite. And this one honestly
took like four or five tries to get it
right. But take a look at this.
That's That's super dope. For this
prompt, I will show you briefly right
here, but if you want to get access to
the full prompt, just click the link in
description down below, sign up to my
newsletter, and you will get access to
it. Promise you I won't spam you with
bad emails. It's all about AI stuff.
Now, lastly, to end it off with a
banger, I got this perfume ad.
If people will call this trash, then I'm
going to fight you in the comments.
Like, this is insane to me. Like, this
crazy. I I lack the vocabulary to give
words to this. Literally. Wow. Now, if
you want to try this out yourself, then
use this prompot and you will get some
good results. Be creative with this.
More creativity generates better prompts
in my opinion as long as you have a
clear objective. Other than that, if you
want to try this using Open Art, I will
leave the link for that as well. You can
also use Google Flow if you prefer that.
I use this because it also has like the
image model. It also has like all the
video models that I want to use. That's
my reason for using Open Art. Also,
click the video that's on the screen
right now if you want to learn how you
can make fully AI animated stories like
the one that I'm showing right now.
[Music]
It's honestly quite sick what you can do
with AI